James Cullen Bressack, Filmmaker: And then
every single page I'll write in the same color.
Film Courage: What's the job of a movie director?
James: That's a deep question. I think we've kind
of talked about it throughout this whole interview
but but it's working with actors it's shot listing
the script with the DP it's like really working
with all of the Departments and getting the best
out of everybody while moving towards an overall
vision of the film and then the story and keeping
the story intact keeping the story you're trying
to tell both visually both both creatively and on
a deeper meaning in a deeper sense all together
as one and having the actors be on board for
that once you're hired as a director what are
you looking for with the screenplay what's
your process how do you look at it I to look
for I scripts that have flawed characters that
are that are trying to achieve something great
and I scripts that have villains
that believe that they are
in the right because I think that's interesting to
have those types of conversations with actors and
and dig into that and get into that psychology of
of well why does this person believe that they're
right when they're obviously the bad guy right so
everybody believes that they're the hero of their
own story so finding that mentality and having
those conversations where you might be talking to
the good guy the guy the actor who's playing the
good guy and you're you're completely justified
in this and that then you're talking the actor
that's playing the bad guy and go look this is
how you feel because this guy has wronged you and
blah blah blah so you getting into that psychology
that's interesting so I think I start thinking
of that but also if I'm reading a script and I
don't start seeing the movie when I'm reading
it I don't I know I'm not connecting with it
I have to read it and if I'm reading it and I'm I
start seeing shots that I want to do and going oh
wow this and this if that's not happening then it
just it just means that I'm not connecting with it
interesting will you give it at least another
pass to see did I miss something no yeah if I'm
not connecting with it there it just means that
it's it's just it's not not connecting with the
material I have to start seeing it and going
oh that would be fun to if I find myself going
well how would I shoot that then it means I
want to shoot that that's but if I'm looking
at that going well that's stupid and going here
it doesn't it means I'm not connecting with it
which is interesting because a lot of the the
script's really important to me because I was
raised by a writer and a lot of the scripts
I did early on in my career I wrote myself
and a lot of times I do tweaks on the scripts that
I'm directing that I didn't write I'll tweak out
dialogue or I'll do a little director's password
type stuff on my own but I haven't really fully
written scripts anymore myself since my dad
passed away really it's been much harder to
will myself to to do that because a lot of what
was really fun about writing scripts was being
able to talk to him about what I was writing and
if I would hit some writer's block I'd call him
and he'd talk things out with me on the phone and
then I'd keep going so it's it's definitely been
hard plus I was writing a script with him right
before he passed away and I didn't finish it and
I promised him I would and so I still haven't
done that so it feels weird thinking about
other stories until that one's done so I don't
know at some point I'll write something again
so James you brought some cool stuff here you have
some scripts yeah yeah so I do color-coded notes
for each department so and then I also here I'll
show you well look at the hot seat one real quick
so well this I have my shot list in here as well
but then what I do and I draw little overhead maps
of where I want the blocking to be for each little
location so you see little overhead things in here
with with now we're actually able to print out
what the actual overhead of the the location is
now which is pretty cool so I don't have to draw
it by hand fully but then I'll do this so it'll be
actor hair makeup art props FX Camera lighting
wardrobe and then every single page I'll write
in the same color of what my thoughts are for
for each thing so I it's every page of the whole
script I pre-direct all of it and kind of come
up with thoughts and ideas throughout all of
it and then that was the most recent one because
apparently I didn't discover until the last one
that I could have Whatchamacallit a pens that
were made in that color so what I would do is
just write it out and then use a highlighter to
highlight it before and then I would put little
colored tabs on every single page and where are
the tabs the tabs would color would correspond
with the color coding so I'd go okay if I see a
green tab this is when I'm in the with effects
this is what I got to talk to them about go to
the green tab Pages or if I'm okay this is the
yellow tab Pages or for art go to all the yellow
tab pages to talk to them about that so it's and
then still see look there's the evolution look
at the little little overhead blocking maps
that I was drawing but I was having to draw
the location whereas over here I was able to
oh print out an overhead of the
location didn't have to draw it
I thought that was pretty cool very cool but
yes every page is color coded with different
notes for every department and did you start
doing this from the beginning or was it because
you knew that in the moment knowing this certain
color you could flip to it no matter how much
chaos was around you I started doing that yeah
it was from a trial and error because I so much
so often I'd be I'd come on to set and I'd be
I want to tell you what was I talking about
I'll be right back and then I'd leave right but
what I what I started doing is Okay so this and
I'd talk to them right so I started I started to
write down notes for myself so that if I forgot
what I was trying to say it would be there or if I
was if I was jumbled up or you're moving fast and
because you call cut and you're okay well I got
to talk to the DP about this I got to talk to this
actor about this got attacked that actor about
that I gotta talk to this so you just refer back
to okay well this is what we were thinking great
I have my notes it's all in a thing great that's
all stuff that before even being in the moment
I told myself a week ago that I wanted to do so
I'm Okay cool so that brings it back that brings
us where it is you're shooting a lot of the time
out of order too so it reminds you okay this is
what you felt was important about this scene this
is what was this is the emotion you needed to get
out of this scene this is what needed to happen
with art for this scene that you felt was really
important right this is what you needed the camera
really do for this scene that would get that
emotion great we're all there we're all in
the same place we understand it so it just brings
you back to what that goal was and it's all stuff
that you've gone over with the actors with the
DP with the production designer with the costume
designer with the makeup artist before making the
movie you did that in pre-production so it's it's
just gently reminding people of the conversations
you've had and and looking for stuff and and it's
just pre-planning for everything so you have an
eventuality of maybe something isn't there maybe
the chalkboard isn't there so you can go okay that
wasn't that important to me this was so let's move
to this next piece of what this would be how many
group meetings do you usually have before filming
with who each department each department you
hopefully a lot the more the better hopefully as
many as possible do you do a script read with all
ever a table read with all the actors or sometimes
if you're lucky enough to have all the actors
available but mostly because that's the one thing
that could be great to always do that because
sometimes people will say something and on the day
you're just adjusting words because they're that
doesn't really make as much sense if this person's
saying this or this this might on the page read
normal but when somebody says it you're that's
not how people talk and it's not the fault of the
actor's performance it's the fault of the words on
the page so you want to change some of the words
because a perfect example is maybe somebody's
saying I am very mad at you because of this right
and that's their line and it's it seems cheesy but
it could easily just be changed ah off right go
yourself or or leave me alone right but it gives
you the same emotion that you needed right so
maybe you're just man they wouldn't be saying
that they'd say this in this moment right so then
you're changing it or maybe it's just as simple as
I'm pissed at you because of yada yada and
you're just chop that off I'm pissed at you right
get rid of the yada yada so sometimes it just
yeah message taken yeah it's good you're right
because maybe it's too formal and it's overwritten
yeah it's too stiff and somebody wouldn't say that
exactly but you sometimes it looks normal on the
page but you need to hear people say it before
you're oh that doesn't sound right what do you
think about directors though that they're so stiff
with the script they won't there's no you have
to say the line I can't have you deviate from it
that's not me I think that's I think
I'm I'm a very strong believer of say
the gist of the line as long as you say kind
of what the intention of the line was make it
your own as long as it doesn't throw off
what the actor across from you is doing
and as long as they're aware of what you're going
to do that's how I feel however I always say this
I also I'm a firm believer as far as wardrobe
goes it's I might talk with a costume designer
about what I want the actor to wear but then I to
let the actor make their decisions from there and
let them do everything and what they and what
they don't and and stuff and shape it and I'm
very very giving in that sense towards the actor
because I feel personally that the wardrobe that
the actor puts on is is the first thing they do
to become that character and so I don't want to
dictate if I've talked to them about how we feel
about the character and we're on the same page I
don't want to dictate to them what they what
they they feel this person would be wearing
for their shoes if a certain shoe is how they
feel is the emotion of what this person is or
the jacket that they wear usually what I say is
it's more of a as long as you're not coming in a
clown costume I'm I'm usually cool with what
the person wants to wear because I feel I've
talked more in emotion and color palette
and let them just kind of go from there.